حكوماتنا تانياهو فاشله في التعامل مع
الفلسطينيين وجيشنا هاجم غزه مرات عده لكن
الكلمه الفصل ليست بايدينا بل في يد
الفلسطينيين لان الامر متعلق بطبيعه رد
الجهاد الاسلامي وحماس هكذا يرى الاعلام
الاسرائيلي والمتحدثون في استوديوهاته
حمله التصعيد الحاليه في غزه
كنا هناك في غزه لمده 51 يوما ولمده ثلاثه
ايام ولمده 20 يوما وسبعه ايام لكن لا احد
منا يستطيع ان يعلم كم ستستمر هذه الحمله
فالامر متعلق بطبيعه رد حماس والجهاد
الاسلامي
ومن تداعيات التصعيد الحالي في غزه تفكك
ما يسميه الاحتلال الجبهه الداخليه شباب
يتراجعون عن دعم بنكفير ويرفضون دعوه
الجيش بالالتحاق بالجبهات كما ان من
تداعياته تاثر الاقتصاد وتوقف حياه مئات
الالاف من الناس
الاعلامي الاسرائيلي قوه الجائزه انا خائف
انا ارى جنودا لا يتحدث عنهم احد فقط
عائلاتهم هي من يتحدث عنهم بدل ان
يعيدونهم الشعور بالامن يؤول الى الصفر
انتخبت من جفير واقنعت اخرين بالتصويت له
لكنني الان مصاب بخيبه امل لقد قال انه
سيعالج مساله المخربين لكنه لم يفعل شيئا
اعتقد ان المنظمات الارهابيه حققت انجازا
حيث فرضت على الدوله ان تبقى على اهبه
الاستعداد وهذا امر يعطل مسار الحياه
الطبيعيه لمئات الالاف من المواطنين ويؤثر
على الاقتصاد
اخفاق اخر حققه التصعيد في غزه يتجسد حسب
متحدثين في الاعلام الاسرائيلي ومسؤولين
سابقين في الفشل في التفريق بين الساحات
في غزه والضفه ولبنان
منظمات واعيه للاسف الش ديد وقد اكتشفوا
الاستراتيجيات الاسرائيليه اذ لم يعد سرا
ان الهدف هو التفريق بين المنظمات في غزه
والضفه وبين هذه الساحات وبين لبنان
وسوريا وكانت اجابتهم محاوله توحيد كل هذه
الساحات